back at the shop it's almost past time
so we have a plan we have the pool we
have the scale we have our little Klaus
so the first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna weigh him normally then
we're gonna give him a bath getting his
dry weight of nineteen point four pounds
is the easy part
now it's time to get wet just right
right on him with eight dogs at home
Rachel's got bath time down pat Elijah
not so much yeah I have no dogs I'm a
cat person well I like cats I'm not like
I'm not furry every fiber of this furry
frame wants to shimmy from nose to tail
the hardest part was not getting the
dogs to shake because that's all they
want to do is shake Elijah grabs a
reading of twenty point four pounds not
a second too soon then it's back on the
scale for those vital post shake
particulars twenty point one pounds
point three of a pound doesn't sound
like much but math genius and college
sophomore Canon soon confirms that the
myth is off to a promising start the
results are that class lost about sixty
percent of his water weight in one shake
cycle it's not seventy percent but it's
still very impressive impressive enough
for Elijah to propose his pet theory of
comparative species shaking we're gonna
test to see if humans can shake water
out of their hair just like dogs can
shake water out of their fur
no prizes for guessing which human just
like Klaus Elijah first gets weighed dry
then it's dunk time three two one go
[Music]
Elijah's now Wade with his main wringing
wet and then so let's get the data on
dude versus dog
I gained 0.7 pounds after my hair was
soaked and I lost 0.2 pounds when I like
shook out my hair okay
math man what is that in percentage that
is twenty-eight point five percent of
the water loss not too shabby
still no match for Klaus but to give
this myth a fair shake they'll need a
much bigger sample size